تعد قاعده وانجلز الجويه قاعده استراتيجيه
بالنسبه الى روسيا فهي تضم قاذفات من نوع
توبوليف 95 وتبوليف 160 قادره على حمل
صواريخ كروز مسلحه نوويه او بذخائر
تقليديه هذه القاعده التي تبعد نحو 600
كيلو متر عن اوكرانيا تعرضت لهجوم لطائره
مسيره قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها
اوكرانيه
بدون طيار على ارتفاع منخفضتنا اقترابها
من مطار انجاز العسكري في منطقه ثلاثه
جنود دروس من الطاقه الفني كانوا في
المطار اصيبوا بجروح قاتله نتيجه سقوط
حطام الطائره المسيره حسابات روسيه
واوكرانيه على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
تحدثت عن تدمير عدد من طائرات قاعدته وهو
ما لا يمكن التحقق منه بشكل مستقل وسبق
لروسيا ان اعلنت في مطلع الشهر الجاري
تعرض القائد نفسها لهجوم بطائره مسيره
اوكرانيه ما يدل على قدره بعض الاجهزه
الاوكرانيه على اعدي ساعات الروسيه
المضاده للطائره
وتزامن هذا الهجوم مع اعلان جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي الروسي عن انه قتل من وصفهم
بالمخربين الاوكرانيين اثناء محاولاتهم
التسلل الى منطقه بريانس الروسيه وبحوزتهم
اسلحه ومتفجرات وسبق لروسيا ان اتهمت
اوكرانيا بمهاجمه اراضيها عندما نسبت
اليها المسؤوليه عن الهجوم بشاحنه مفخخه
على الجسر الواصل بين روسيا وشبه جزيره
القرم في اوائل تشرين الاول اكتوبر الماضي
ما شكل نقطه تتحول في الحرب على اوكرانيا
واعطى سريعه للرئيس بلادي مير بوتن
لمضاعفه الضربات ضد البنيه التحتيه للطاقه
الاخرى من جانبها امتنعت كيف عن تبني اي
هجمات داخل الاراضي الروسيه